el museo que bon jovi le dio carta
blanca le dijeron puedes traer mujeres
voces de áfrica y me llamó y me dijo
entonces kgs qué te parece venir a
compartir esto conmigo y
le di las gracias y hoy estoy aquí y
estoy muy contenta le agradezco a este
gran hombre me alegra que estés acá
[Música]
el gran hombre es un artista camerunés
polifacético clic base en el marco de la
exposición en el camino de los cacicatos
de camerún de lo visible a lo invisible
el museo que braille jacques chirac le
dio carta blanca para invitar a tres
músicas a dar un concierto tres mujeres
que según él representan la nueva ola
afronte temporánea en un intento de
responder a la compleja pregunta cómo
puede áfrica reconectarse con su
identidad la moda junto con la música
podrían tener la respuesta a su lista
tyson foods temple makes utilizó la moda
por ejemplo para expresar mi deseo de
romper con la norma y asumir la persona
que soy a través de mis elecciones lo
cual es una noción bastante compleja
cuando uno dice que esto es lo que
quiero es lo que me gusta
es completamente abstracto y colegios
sin sentido en que estamos predispuesto
a que nos guste lo que nos gusta e
incluso lo que creemos que nos gusta de
hecho nos gusta algo porque fuimos
educados en un contexto determinado y
cómo podemos emanciparnos eso
cuando estamos condicionados simplemente
por lass referencias a nuestro alrededor
y que en cierto modo enmarcan todo
nuestro camino
[Música]
qué
y el hecho de que me pinte las uñas y
que me vista de cierta manera a menudo
me reclaman por eso la gente me dice es
que porque te pones eso pero para mí son
cosas que definen completamente mi
visión que es preguntarme a mí mismo
cómo crea un tipo de corredor de
libertad para avanzar en el día a día lo
cual es muy difícil en una sociedad
donde la gente es uniforme
como la boya por ejemplo
a veces me considera un maquillaje un
líder de la resistencia
en el sentido en que los llamados más
quizás en camerún en su momento eran
personas que luchaban por el amor y por
la libertad
por la emancipación de la mujer por la
convivencia
y esas personas eran consideradas como
bandidos porque luchaban contra los
intereses capitalistas capitalista sin
embargo los llamados maquillar en
camerún luchaban por el interés común de
paul y sobre todo para que pudiéramos
vivir como hombres libres vivos
eliminar las separaciones entre las
artes ese es el credo del artista franco
senegalesa mundo canta baila y si bien
crea sus propias prendas los trajes que
usa en tarimas son diseñados por casas
comprometidas con la moda ética en un
estilo afro futurista coherente con el
mensaje que transmite a través de sus
canciones mis canciones cuentan mi
historia es cierto pero también cuentan
la historia de las mujeres en general
les dan mucho ánimo a las mujeres mucho
ánimo a los jóvenes para que despertemos
para que explotemos todas nuestras
capacidades pero hago hincapié en la
educación
hablo mucho de educación de la
importancia de la educación y de la
fuerza de la educación así que todo eso
aparece en mi proyecto y es cierto que
hablo mucho de las mujeres 'amigable' o
se ha hecho un lugar más bien masculino
del rap maliense en el escenario usa un
traje inspirado en la etnia bambara
complementado con una bonita de
maquillar el rapacidad un medio de
expresión para mí no solo para hablar de
los problemas de nuestras sociedades de
todas estas cosas que les son impuestas
especialmente a las mujeres a las
jóvenes y a través de la música trato de
hablar de esas cosas de decir que
ciertas cosas son injustas y que podemos
revisar ciertas cosas también así que
habla de la sociedad maliense de la
sociedad africana en generaciones lo más
difícil para usted hoy todos somos
diferentes todos tenemos cualidades
diferentes y toda persona tiene el
derecho a creer en sí misma a conseguir
los medios para lograr y a veces se nos
impide creer en nosotros mismos seguir
nuestros sueños porque o somos mujeres o
somos hombres y creo que en el siglo 21
este tipo de ideas deben desaparecer
dejarle espacio al libre albedrío y
sobre todo a la pasión y al compromiso
de los demás
estos cascabeles de frutos secos atados
con rafia curtida y tejida que carey se
fox o se ata a los tobillos eran usados
exclusivamente por los hombres durante
la danza de guerra cubana en camerún hoy
en día esto ya no es así
el escenario es lenguaje corporal el
lenguaje de la vestimenta
porque como eligió este atuendo
la tela se llama leyendo es una tela
ancestral tejida manualmente con lana y
para mí es un vínculo con la tierra me
recuerda de dónde vengo
hoy estoy en el museo que volví pero
vengo de alguna parte y donde quiera que
vaya voy con mi cultura con mi
diferencia
para que la gente descubra que más allá
de las fronteras el mundo sea como un
pueblo es un pueblo lleno de diversidad
y es a través de todos estos colores que
podemos encontrar el equilibrio y el
lenguaje universal
al final de su concierto caray si fotos
o invita a blick vas a acompañarla en el
escenario el público está alegre los
pueblos mami que le ibas a de camerún
están unidos en elogio a la diversidad